I have a concern about critical, critical theory, critical this, this whole,
this whole, everything that's happening right now.
I believe it was a Trojan horse. I believe that that, um,
that James Lindsey and how he described it as a Trojan horse,
is he's exactly right on it's coming into our churches. Um,
do the division that it's causing right now is insane because like you said,
it's another gospel. It's another religion it's like, uh, because once again,
they have their own epistemology. So the way that they discover truth is,
is from a positional standpoint. So, so how do I respond to that.
Before you mentioned the sort of lefty versus conservative,
uh, demographics that you're dealing with in the church? Um,
so as we've watched this culture war just like explode all over the place,
I know that all sorts of churches, temples,
virtually every organization,
secular or not is dealing with some sort of like internal split over how to
deal with everything that's happening these days,
literally from Corona virus to black lives matter and everything in between.
What, what version of that are you seeing these days?
Yeah. Uh,
there's definitely a political part of everything. Um,
and dude, this is insane. Like it's insane. I keep on telling my friends.
I'm sure that all your friends are just going, what, what is happening in 2020?
Um, you know, for there, there's a, there's a,
there's a conversation in the church right now,
politically about the threshold of, um,
the threshold of religious Liberty versus, um, you know,
government needing to, you know, keep it, uh,
tabs and a lid on coronavirus. Um, and so we're kind of, I guess,
exploring that threshold, um, you know, you got people who,
uh, th that's that's, that's absolutely fine falls along ideological lines,
right? So there's, there's, it seems like there's two types of Americans.
There's ones that want to, they, they, they have a huge trust in the government.
My wife is one of my wife is an Australian. I'm a Canadian,
but my wife is like, she trusts the government. She's just like, they are,
you know, they love us and I want to be, she told me last night, she's like,
I want to be nannied. I like, like a hot moment. Um, I was just like,
have you read all of that? Totally. Um, so there, you got my,
my wife, Jasmine, and then you got me and I'm like the most distrusting,
uh, you know, uh, person of, of government because yeah, I, you know,
like they, uh, who are these angels, you know,
like the old argument who are these angels that are going to make all these
rights decisions for us. So there's that,
that's a huge conversation of the church and that alone Dave was tearing us
apart. Right? Like,
so you got pastors like calling up pastors or people calling up people like in
the, in the faith community, just being like,
you need to trust the government authorities from God. And then, um,
and then now you have, of course, uh, you know, George Floyd's death,
which was horrific and tragic. Um, and, uh,
you have black lives matter. Um, the organization, um,
that's kind of, uh,
occupied some space in wake of the George Floyd killing and then a
mod Arbery, um, because it, it looks,
um,
it looks from social media that young black men are
being hunted down and killed. Um, so, so yeah,
you have this major space and it's it,
this is another thing that's kind of dividing us right now.
It's just like the narrative to believe and, um,
and what we ought to do about it. And, and regardless of if you,
if you believe that narrative or not, you know,
Christians are called to mourn with those who mourn and weep with those who
weep. Um, so finding that threshold of going, okay,
I might not agree with the political narrative,
but I'm called to, uh, to stand alongside, you know,
people who are in my life that regardless of whether I know it, whether or not,
I believe that they are, their emotions are rooted in any kind of reality.
And I'm arguing from a, you know, if you're a conservative, you know,
like I I've, I have a responsibility towards them to love them. You know,
like my wife is terrified of airplanes. Um,
it's not rooted in anything logical at all. Um,
but I'm the one that's stuck holding the bag and comforting her and getting her
Xanax when we're on a flight. And, you know, so there's an element of that.
If you're a conservative, uh,
that you have a responsibility towards the people that you're in community with
and you're living life with, and, you know, you know,
quoting stats at my wife, doesn't help her flight anxiety,
you know, like, so finding how is the mess right now?
Yeah. How,
how worried are you though that letting in this sort of different,
what I would call a religious belief system, social justice,
that once it enters the institution enters the church,
that in many ways it will just, it will rot from the inside.
All of the good things that you've been talking about. I mean,
this is what we've sort of seen happen to every secular institution it's
happening to the New York times, it's happening to the Washington post,
it's happening to Harvard and Princeton and all of our liberal institutions. Um,
so I'm sort of fascinated where with this idea that it could be entering,
you know,
sort of conservative or religious institutions and that they may not even have
the correct defense mechanisms to, to purge it, or.
That's exactly what's happening. So it's not necessarily,
so for me, I've tried to dance line where like, you know,
the idea of black lives matter is like, it's an idea.
It's a saying I've sort of divorced it from the organization.
Um, they don't like that, but sourced it from the organization because,
you know, the black lives do matter. And so if there are instances of where,
you know, there's police brutality that doesn't seem to fit, you know,
the resident, I mean, you know, as if, as we, as we examine the data,
that's one of the big ones that we know that, that, you know, the, uh,
Harvard Rowan's, um, uh, his paper,
and we know that the, the study that was done, uh,
Heather McDonald obviously lays this all out.
But one of the things that I have a giant question Mark over is the police
brutality part. Um, I don't know if we're nailing that, you know, well, and so,
uh, let's say that you're like me where you're going, okay. The shooting part,
you know, there's, there's no racial bias.
That's been detected by three major studies. Um,
but police brutality, do you have a question on that? Like,
why are 30% of blacks being, you know, accused of resisting arrest?
Are they resisting? Is that what's happening or the police, you know, being, um,
antagonistic towards them or whatever. So, so let's, let's just say for example,
that there is some antagonism, it needs to be dialed back.
Um, so I stand with my brother who feels he's, he's terrified.
Okay. And he's, and he's like, Nate, you know, like,
I just feel like black doesn't matter. Okay. Man, black lives matter. Okay.
I'm with you on black lives. Like I'll say that now the organization,
they believe in the [inaudible] of the family,
which is doing nobody a service, particularly the black community in America.
Right. So, um, so, so for me,
obviously I have some fat or theological concerns to fry. Um,
but I'm walking this line where I'm in community with, with, with,
with my black brothers and sisters. And so, um, so for me,
like once again, I have a concern about critical, critical theory,
critical this, this whole, this whole, everything that's happening right now,
I believe it was a Trojan horse. I believe that, that, um,
that Jane Lindsey and how he described it as a Trojan horses,
he's exactly right on it's coming into our churches. Um,
do the division that it's causing right now is insane because like you said,
it's another gospel. It's another one religion. It's like, uh,
because once yeah, they have their own epistemology.
So the way that they discovered truth is, is from a positional standpoint.
So, so how do I respond to that? It's, it's, it's,
it's almost an impossible dance, but I have to show rational compassion,
not empathy, because empathy, uh, is,
you know, as, as we've seen in the last, like 10,
15 years in psychology is dangerous and your biases come into empathy,
I have to have what's called rational compassion.
So I have to reasonably move through the data,
move through the things that are happening using my Christian worldview and
frame and framework and my epistemology, you know, and,
and then as I'm checking these, these movements and going, okay, these were,
are man's right. Cause everything has a demand. We demand that no,
that you overhaul, uh, you know, as James says, you know,
you can't tear down the master's house, the master's tools.
So we have to completely change how we structure, not,
not just the way we structured our church organization,
but we also demand that like the way that you go about finding
truth changes as well. And so at that point, um,
for me, I'm not going to fight peripherals like in any good argument,
you always argue first principles. So you don't argue peripherals.
And so for me, when it comes to the black lives matter movement,
when it comes to the things that are happening on the streets and the protests,
et cetera, I'm not going to, there are some things I think that are peripheral.
And as conservatives, we get a little bit sidetracked by. And so to me,
the critical theory thing, and this is why I think James Lindsey, um,
is just so on the money right now is because it's the,
you don't go after the fruit. You go after the root. And to me,
critical theory is the root of this giant problem. It's,
it's the reason why that the political narrative has been spun the way it is.
And so to me, that's, that's what I'm going after,
while holding the hand of people that are hurting.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about
spirituality, instead of nonstop yelling, check out our spirituality playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.